YUFEI ZHAO: We've been
spending the past few lectures
discussing Szemeredi's
Regularity Lemma.
And one of the
first applications
that we discussed of
the Regularity Lemma
is the triangle removal Lemma.
So today, I want to
revisit this topic
and show you a strengthening
of the Removal Lemma
for which new regularity
techniques are needed.
But first, recall the
graph removal Lemma.
In the graph removal Lemma,
we have that for every graph H
and epsilon bigger than zero,
there exists some delta such
that if an N vertex graph
has fewer than delta
and to the number of vertices
of H, many copies of H,
then it can be made H-free by
removing fewer than epsilon N
squared edges.
Even in the case when
H is a triangle, when
this is called a triangle
removal Lemma, even
in that case, basically
the regularity method
is more or less the only
way that we currently
know how to prove this theorem.
So we saw this a
few lectures ago.
What I would like
to discuss today
is a variant of
this result where
instead of considering
copies of H,
we're now considering
induced copies of H. OK?
So this is the induced
graph removal Lemma
where the only difference is
that the hypothesis is now
going to be changed to
induced copies of H.
And the conclusion
is that you can
make the graph induced H-free.
So let me remind
you, the difference
between the induced
graph subgraph
and the usual subgraph.
So we say that H is an induced
copy of G, induced subgraph
of G. If one can obtain H from
G by deleting vertices of G.
You're not allowed
to delete edges,
but only allowed
to delete vertices.
So in other words,
the four cycle
is not an induced
subgraph because, well,
if you select four vertices, you
don't generate this four cycle.
You get extra edges.
So it is a subgraph, but
not an induced subgraph.
So it is a theorem, the
induced graph removal Lemma.
So it's a theorem,
and let's discuss
how we may prove that theorem.
Question.
OK, question is, why is it
stronger than the graph removal
lemma?
So it's not stronger, but
we'll see the relationship
between the two.
So I claim that it is more
difficult to do this theorem.
Any more questions?
So let's pretend for a second
that whatever's in here
is not quite true.
So here's an example.
For example, if your H is
three isolated vertices.
So what is that saying?
We're looking at
copies of H which
are three isolated vertices.
So really you are looking at
triangles in g complement.
So this is exactly the
triangle removal lemma
in the complement of g, but
you can't get rid of these guys
by removing edges.
So we need to make
the modification
where instead of
removing these edges,
we need to both remove and
add by adding or deleting.
So maybe at the same time.
So you're allowed to add some
edges, delete some edges.
But in total, you change no more
than epsilon n squared edges.
So those are sometimes also
known as the edit distance.
You're allowed to change edges.
So you can add edges
and delete edges.
Any questions about
the statement?
All right, so let's
think about how would you
prove this result following
the proof that we did
for the triangle removal lemma.
So let's pretend that
we go through this proof
and think about
what could go wrong.
So remember in the application
of the removal lemma,
so the recipe has three steps.
The first step we
do a partition.
So we partition applying
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
to this partition.
And the second step
is do a cleaning,
and the two key things
that happen in the cleaning
is we remove low density pairs
of parts and irregular pairs.
And the third step
we claim that once we
do the cleaning, once
we remove those edges,
the resulting
graphs should be H3.
Because if we're not H3, then
by considering the vertex parts
where H lie and applying
the counting lemma,
you can generate many
more copies of H.
So these were the three
main steps in the proof
of the triangle removal lemma.
So let's see what
happens when we
try to apply this strategy
to the induced version.
I mean, the partition you still
do the regularity partition.
Nothing really changes there.
So let's see in the
cleaning step what happens.
For low density pairs--
well, so now we need to think
about not just low density
pairs, but also
high density pairs.
Because in the induced, we
think about edges and non-edges
at the same time.
So you might think of a
strategy which is like the edge
density is less than n.
So less than epsilon, then
you remove all those edges.
And if the edge density is
bigger than 1 plus epsilon,
then you add all
of those edges in.
So this is the
natural generalization
of our strategy for
triangle removal
lemma for the induced setting.
So so far,
everything's still OK.
But now what would you do
for the irregular pairs?
That's problematic.
Previously for
triangle removal lemma,
we just said if a pair is
irregular, get rid of that pair
and it will never show
up in the counting stage.
But that strategy
no longer works.
Because for example, if
your graph H being counted
is this here, you do the
regularity partition,
and one of your
pairs is irregular.
So you, let's say, get rid of
all those edges in between.
Then maybe you have
some embedding of H
where you are going to
use the removed edges.
And now you don't
have a counting lemma.
You cannot say, I found this
copy of H in my changed graph.
And by the counting lemma I
could get many copies of H
because you have no control over
this irregular pair anymore.
So the fact that you
have to add and remove
makes it unclear
what to do here,
and this is a big obstacle
in the application
of the regularity lemma to
the induced removal lemma
application.
Any questions about
this obstacle?
So make sure you understand
why this is an issue.
Otherwise you won't
really appreciate
what will happen next.
So somehow we need to find some
kind of regularity partition
to get no irregular pairs.
So the question
is, is there a way
to partition so that there
are no irregular pairs?
For those of you who have
started your homework
problem on time, you realize
that the answer is no.
So one of the
homework problems is
for you to show that for
the specific graph known
as the half graph.
So there was an
example in homework
that for the half graph--
so you'll see in the
homework what this graph is--
you cannot partition it so that
you get rid of all irregular
pairs.
Irregular pairs are
necessary in the statement
of regularity lemma.
So what I want to show
you today is a way
to do what's called a strong
regularity lemma in which you
obtain a somewhat different
consequence that will allow
you to get rid of
irregular pairs
in the more restricted setting.
So this is the issue,
the irregular pairs.
Before telling you what
this regularity lemma is,
I want to give you a
small generalization
of the induced graph removal
lemma, or just a different way
to think about the statement.
And you can think of it as
a colorful version instead
of induced where you
have edges and no edges.
You can also have colored edges.
So colorful removal
lemma, although this name
is not standard.
So colorful-- so when
we talk about graphs,
it's colorful graph
removal lemma.
So for every k, r, and epsilon,
there exists delta such
that if curly H is a set of
r edge of the complete graph
on little k vertices.
So edge coloring just
means using r colors
to color the edges.
So there are no restrictions
about what are allowed,
what are not allowed.
So just a set of
possible r colorings.
Then if the complete graph--
say it slightly differently.
So then every r edge coloring
of the complete graph
on n vertices with fewer than
delta fraction of its k vertex
subsets, say k vertex subgraphs,
belonging to the script H.
So every such graph can be made
curly H free by recoloring,
so using the same r colors, a
fewer than epsilon fraction.
So less than epsilon fraction
of the edges of this kn.
So in particular, the
version that we just stated,
the induced version, so the
induced graph removal lemma,
is the same as having two
colors and H having exactly one
red-blue coloring of k
of the complete graph
on the same number
of vertices as H.
So you color red the edges
and blue the non-edges,
for instance.
And you're saying, I want to
color the big complete graph
with red and blue in such a way
that there are very few copies
of that pattern.
So then I can recolor
the red and blue
in a small number of places to
get rid of all such patterns.
So having a colored
pattern somewhere
in your graph in this
complete graph coloring
is the same as having
an induced subgraph.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So after done--
like the statement after done
is a really long sentence.
Can I--
YUFEI ZHAO: Yeah, OK.
So every r edge coloring of kn
with a small number of patterns
can be made h-free by recoloring
a small fraction of the edges.
So like in a triangle
removal lemma,
every graph with a small
number of triangles
can be made
triangle-free by removing
a small number of edges.
Any other questions?
So this is a restatement of
the induced removal lemma
with a bit more generality.
It's OK if you like
this one more or less,
but let's talk about the
induced version from now on.
But the same proofs that
I will talk about also
applies to this version where
you have somewhat more colors.
So the variant of the
regularity lemma that we'll need
is known as a strong
regularity lemma.
To state the strong
regularity lemma,
let me recall a notion that came
up in the proof of Szemeredi's
regularity lemma.
And this was the
notion of an energy.
So recall that if you have
a partition, denoted P. So
if this is a partition of
the vertex set of a graph, G,
and here n is the
number of vertices,
we defined this notion of energy
to be this quantity denoted
q, which is basically a
squared mean of the densities
between vertex parts
appropriately normalized
if the vertexes do not
all have the same size.
In the proof of Szemeredi's
regularity lemma,
there was an important
energy increment
step which says that if you have
some partition p that is not
epsilon regular, then there
exists a refinement, Q.
And this refinement has
the property that Q has
a small number of pieces, or
not too large as a function of P
So it's bounded at
least in terms of P.
But also if P is not epsilon
regular, then the energy of Q
is significantly larger than
the energy of P. So remember,
this was an important step in
the proof of regularity lemma.
So to state the strong
regularity lemma,
we need that notion of energy.
And the statement of the
strong regularity lemma,
if you've never seen this
kind of thing before,
will seem a bit
intimidating at first
because it involves a whole
sequence of parameters.
But we'll get used to it.
So instead of one
epsilon parameter,
now you have a sequence
of positive epsilons.
And part of the strength
of this regularity lemma
is that depending on the
application you have in mind,
you can make the sequence
go to zero pretty quickly.
Thereby increasing the strength
of the regularity lemma.
So there exists some m
bound, which depends only
on your epsilons such that
every graph has not just one,
but now we're going to get a
pair of vertex partitions P
and Q with the
following properties.
So first, P refines--
so Q refines P. So it's
a pair of partitions,
one refining the other.
The number of parts
of Q is bounded
just like in the usual
regularity lemma.
The partition P
epsilon 0 regular.
And here is the new part
that's the most important one.
Q is very epsilon regular.
So it's not just
epsilon 0 regular,
it's epsilon sub the number
of parts of P regular.
So you should think of
this as extremely regular
because you get to choose what
the sequence of epsilon is.
And finally, the energy
difference between P and Q
is not too big.
This is the statement of
the strong regularity lemma.
It produces for you
not just one partition,
but a pair of partitions.
And in this pair
of partitions, you
have one partition, P,
which is similar to the one
that we obtained from
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
is some epsilon 0 regular, but
we also get a refinement Q.
And this Q is extremely regular.
So you can think
that is P, then Q
is an extremely
regular refinement
of P. Any questions
about the statement
of the strong regularity lemma?
So the sequence of
epsilons gives you
flexibility on how to apply it,
but let's see how to prove it.
And the proof is once you
understand how this works,
conceptually it's pretty short.
But let me do it slowly
so that we can appreciate
this sequence of epsilons.
And the idea is that we
will repeatedly apply
Szemeredi's regularity lemma.
So start with the
regularity lemma.
We'll apply it
repeatedly to generate
a sequence of partitions.
So first, let me remind you
a statement of Szemeredi's
regularity lemma.
This is slightly
different from the one
that we stated, but comes
out of the same proof.
So for every epsilon,
there exists some m0
which depends on epsilon such
that for every partition P0,
so starting with
some partition--
so actually, let me
start with just P.
So if you start with some
partition of the vertex set
of g, there exists a refinement
P prime of P into at most--
OK, so the refinement has is
such that with each part of P
refined into at
most m0 parts such
that P prime, the new
partition, is epsilon regular.
So this is a statement of
Szemeredi's regularity lemma
that we will apply repeatedly.
So in the version that
we've seen before,
we would start with
a trivial partition.
And applying
refinements repeatedly
in the proof to get a partition
into a bounded number of parts
such that the final
partition is epsilon regular.
But instead, in the proof
of the regularity lemma
if you start with not
a trivial partition
but start with a given partition
and run this exact same proof,
you find this consequence.
Except now you can guarantee
that the final partition
is a refinement of the
one that you are given.
So let's apply the
statement, and we obtain
a sequence of partitions of g--
the vertex set of g--
starting with P0 being a
trivial partition, and so on.
Such that each partition,
each P sub i plus 1
refines the previous
one, and such
that each P sub i plus 1 is
epsilon sub a P sub i regular.
So you apply the regularity
lemma with parameter
based on the number of
parts you currently have.
Applied to the
current partition,
you get a finer partition
that's extremely regular.
And you also know
that the number
of parts of the new
partition is bounded in terms
of the previous partition.
All right.
Any questions so far?
So now we get this
sequence of partitions.
We can keep on doing this.
So g could be arbitrarily
large, but eventually we
will be able to obtain
the last condition here,
which is the only thing
that is missing so far.
So since the energy is
bounded between 0 and 1,
there exists some i at
most 1 over epsilon 0
such that the energy goes
up by less than epsilon 0.
Because otherwise your
energy would exceed 1.
So now let's set
P to be this Pi,
and Q to be this,
the refinement--
the next term in the partition.
And what we find is that the--
so then you have basically
all the conditions.
So p is epsilon 0 regular,
because it is epsilon--
the previous term, which is
at most epsilon 0 regular.
And you have this one as
well, and this one as well.
And we want to show that
the number of parts of Q
is bounded.
And that's basically
because each time there
was a bound on the number
of parts which depends only
on the regularity
parameters, and you're
repeating that bound a
bounded number of times.
So Q is-- so it's bounded as
a function of the sequence
of epsilons-- this infinite
vector of epsilons,
but it is a bounded number.
You're only iterating this
bound a bounded number of times.
And that finishes the proof.
Any questions?
It may be somewhat mysterious
to you right now why we do this,
so we'll get that
application a second.
But for now, I just want to
comment a bit on the bounds.
Of course, the bounds depend
on what epsilon i's do you use.
And typically, you
want the epsilon i's
to decrease with more
parts that you have.
And with almost all
reasonable applications
of this regularity lemma,
the strong regularity lemma--
so for example, with epsilon
i being some epsilon divided
by, let's say, i plus 1 or
any polynomial of the i's--
or you can even let it decay
quicker than that, as well.
You see, basically what
happens is that you
are applying this m0 bound.
m0 applied in succession
1 over epsilon times.
In the regularity lemma, we
saw that the m0 that comes out
of Szemeredi's graph regularity
lemma is the tower function.
So the tower function,
that's a tower of i
is defined to be the exponential
function iterated i times.
So of course, I'm
being somewhat loose
here with the exact dependence,
but you get the idea
that now we want to apply
the tower function i times.
Instead of iterating
the exponential i times,
now you iterate the
tower function i times.
And some of you laughing, this
is an incredibly large number.
It's even larger than
the tower function.
So in literature, especially
around the regularity lemma,
this function where you
iterate the tower function i
times is given the name wowzer.
[LAUGHTER] As in, wow,
this is a huge number.
So it's a step up in
the Ackerman hierarchy.
So if you repeat the
wowzer function i times,
you move up one ladder
in the Ackerman hierarchy
and this hierarchy of
rapidly growing functions.
But in any case, it's bounded
and that's good enough for us.
Any questions so far?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: What do you
call like [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: Yes, so
question is, what do you
call wowzer iterated?
I'm not aware of a
standard name for that.
Actually, even the
name wowzer somehow
is very common in the
combinatorics community,
but I think most people
outside this community
will not recognize this word.
Any more questions?
So another way it's a step
up in Ackerman hierarchy.
So it's enumerated one,
two, three, four, you know,
if you keep going up.
All right.
Another remark about this
strong regularity lemma
is that it will be
convenient for us-- actually,
some are more essential compared
to our previous applications--
to make the parts equitable.
So P and Q equitable.
And basically, the parts
are such that all the--
the partitions are such that
all the parts have basically
the same number of vertices.
So I won't make it
precise, but you can do it.
It's not too hard to do it.
And you can prove
it similar to how
I described how to modify the
proof of the regularity level.
So I won't belabor
that point, but we'll
use the equitable version.
All right, so how does one
use this regularity lemma?
Let me state a
corollary, and let
me call this a corollary
star because you actually
need to do some work
to get it to follow
from the strong
regularity lemma.
But the corollary is
the version that we
will apply that if you
start with a decreasing
sequence of this epsilon,
then there exists a delta such
that the following is true.
Every n vertex graph has an
equitable vertex partition,
call it i through the
k, and a subset Wi
of each Vi such that the
following properties hold.
First, all the W's
are fairly large.
They're at least
constant proportion
of the total vertex set.
Between every pair of Wi Wj,
it is epsilon sub k regular.
And this is the point
I want to emphasize.
So here there are not you
regular pairs anymore.
So it is every.
So no irregular pairs
between the Wi's,
and also we need
to include the case
when i equals the j, as well.
So each Wi is
regular with itself.
And furthermore, the edge
densities between the V's are
similar to the edge densities
between the corresponding W's.
And here it is for
most pairs for all
but at most epsilon
k square pairs.
Epsilon 0, yeah.
At most epsilon 0.
Any questions about
the statement?
So let me show you
how you could deduce
the corollary from the
strong regularity lemma.
So first, let me
draw your picture.
So here you have a
regularity partition.
And so these are your
V's, and inside each V
I find a W such that
if I look at the edge
sets between pairwise
blue sets, including
the blue sets with themselves,
it is always very regular.
And also, the edge densities
between the blue sets
is mostly very
similar to the edge
density between their
ambient white sets.
OK, so let me say a few words--
I won't go into
too many details--
about how you might
deduce this corollary
from the strong
regularity lemma.
So first let me
do something which
is slightly simpler, which
is to not yet require
that the blue sets, Wi's,
are regular with themselves.
So without requiring this
as regular so we can obtain
the Wi's by picking
a uniform random part
of the final partition,
Q, inside each part of P
in the strong regularity lemma.
So you have the strong
regularity lemma,
which produces for you a
pair of partitions like that.
So it produces for you
a pair of partitions.
And what we will do is to pick
one of these guys as my W,
pick one of these
guys at random,
and pick one of
those guys at random.
Because W is so extremely
regular, most of these pairs
will be regular.
So with high
probability, you will not
encounter any
irregular pairs if you
pick the W's randomly as parts
of Q. So that's the key point.
Here we're using that
Q is extremely regular.
So all the Wi Wj is
regular for all i not equal
to j with high probability.
But the other thing that we
would like is that the edge
densities between the W's
are similar to those between
the V's.
And for that, we will use this
condition about their energies
being very similar
to each other.
So the third
consequence, C, is--
it's a consequence
of the energy bound.
Because recall that in our proof
of the Szemeredi regularity
lemma there was
an interpretation
of the energy as
the second moment
of a certain random
variable which we called z.
And using that interpretation,
I can write down
this expression like that.
We are here assuming
for simplicity
that Q is completely
equitable, so all the parts
have exactly the same size.
Z of Q is defined to be the
edge density between Vi and Vj
for random ij.
So this is a random variable z.
So you pick pair
of parts uniformly,
or maybe with some weights
if they're not exactly equal.
And you evaluate
the edge density.
So this energy difference
is the difference
between the second moments.
And because Q is
a refinement of P,
it is the case that this
difference of L2 norms
is equal to the second
moment of the difference
of the random variables.
So we saw a version
of this earlier
when we were discussing
variance in the context
of the proof of the
similar irregularity lemma.
Here it's basically the same.
You can either look at this
inequality part by part of V,
or if you like to be
a bit more abstract
then this is actually a
case of Pythagorean theorem.
If you view these as vectors
in a certain vector space,
then you have some
orthogonality.
So you have this sum
of squares identity.
Where does part A come from?
So part A, we want the parts,
that Wi's to be not too small,
but that comes from a bound
on the number of parts of Q.
So so far this more or
less proves the corollary
except for that we
simplified our lives
by requiring just that the i
not equal to j, the Vi Vj's are
regular.
But in the statement
up there, we also want
the Vi's-- so the Wi's ice to
be regular with themselves,
which will be important
for application.
So I won't explain how to do
that, and part of the reason
is that this is also one
of your homework problems.
So in one of the homework
problems problem set 3,
you were asked to prove
that every graph has
a subset of vertices that is of
least constant proportion such
that it is regular with itself.
And the methods
you use there will
be applicable to handle the
situation over here, as well.
So putting all of these
ingredients together,
we get the corollary whereby
you have this picture,
you have this partition.
I don't even require
the Vi's to be regular.
That doesn't matter anymore.
All that matters is that between
the Wi's they are very regular,
and that there are no irregular
parts between these Wi's.
And now we'll be able to go back
to the induced graph removal
lemma where previously we had
an issue with the existence
of irregular pairs in the use of
Szemeredi regularity partition,
and now we have a tool
to get around that.
So next we will see how
to execute this proof,
but at this point hopefully
you already see an outline.
Because you no longer need to
worry about this thing here.
Let's take a quick break.
Any questions so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Why are we
able to [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so
the question was,
there was a step where we were
looking at some expectations
of squares.
And so why was
that identity true?
So if you look back to the
proof of Szemeredi's regularity
lemma, we already saw an
instance of that inequality
in the computation
of the variance.
So you know that the
variance of x, on one
hand it is equal to where
mu is the mean of x.
And on the other hand, it
is equal to this quantity.
So you agree with this formula?
And you can expand it to
prove it, and the thing that--
the question that you
raised basically you
can prove by looking at
this formula part by part.
Any more questions?
So let's now prove the
induced graph removal lemma.
And we'll follow the
regularity partition,
but with a small
twist that Instead
of using Szemeredi's
regularity lemma,
we will use that
corollary up there.
So let's prove the induced
graph removal lemma.
So the three steps.
First, we do partition.
So let's suppose you have a--
so we suppose g is like above.
You have very few
induced copies of H.
Let's apply the corollary to get
a partition of the vertex set
of g into k parts.
And inside each part
I have a W. Satisfying
the following properties
that each Wi Wj
is regular with the
following parameter which
will come out of later when we
need to use the counting lemma.
But it's some number, but
don't worry too much about it.
So here I'm going to--
so let's say H has
little H vertices.
So between Wi Wj
it is this regular.
So we actually have not
yet used the full strength
of the corollary where I can
make the regularity even depend
on k.
So we will not need
that here, but we'll
need it in a later application.
So the exponent is little H.
OK, so other properties are that
the densities between the Vi's
and the Wi's do not differ
by more than epsilon over 2
for all but a small fraction--
so epsilon k squared over 2--
pairs.
And finally, the sizes of the
Wi's are at least delta 0 times
n where delta 0 depends
only on epsilon.
Epsilon and H.
This is the partition step,
so now let's do the cleaning.
In the cleaning step,
basically we're not going to--
I mean, there is no longer an
issue of irregular pairs if we
only look at the Wi's.
So we just need to think
about the low density pairs
or whatever the
corresponding analog is.
And what happens here is
that for every i less than j,
and crucially including
when i equals to j,
if the edge densities
between the W's is too small
then we remove all
edges between Vi and Vj.
And if the edge density
between the Wi's is too big,
then we remove all edges.
So we add all edges
between Vi and Vj.
How many edges do we end
up adding or removing?
So the total number of edges
added or removed from g is--
in this case, so if
the edges density
in g between the Vi's and
Vj's is also very small,
then you do not remove
very many edges.
But most pairs of Vi and
Vj have that property.
So you tidy up
what kind of errors
you can get from here
and there, and you
find that the total number of
edges that are added or removed
from g is less than, let's
say, epsilon n squared.
Maybe even get an
extra factor of 2,
but you know, upon changing
some constant factors,
it's less than
epsilon n squared.
So this is some small
details you can work out.
Here we're using--
asking, how is
the density between Vi and
Vj related to Wi and Wj?
Well, for most pairs of i
and j they're very similar.
And there's a small fraction
of them that are not similar,
but then you lump everything
in to this bound over here.
So maybe I need to--
let me just put a 2
here just to be safe.
All right.
So we deleted a very
small number of edges,
and now we want to show
that the graph that
has resulted from
this modification
does not have any
induced H sub-graphs.
And the final step
is the counting step.
So suppose there
were any induced
H left after the modification.
So I want to show that, in fact,
there must be a lot of H's--
induced H's originally
in the graph,
thereby contradicting
the hypothesis.
So where does this
induced H sit?
Well, you have the V's,
and inside the V's you have
the W's.
So suppose my H is that
graph for illustration.
And in particular,
I have a non-edge.
So I have an edge, and
I also have a non-edge.
So between these two,
that's the non-edge.
So suppose you find a copy
of H in the cleaned-up graph.
Where can that cleaned up--
this copy of H sit?
Suppose you find it here.
The claim now is that if this
copy of H existed here, then
I must be able to find
many such copies of H
in the corresponding
yellow parts.
Because between the yellow
parts you have regularity,
and you also have the
right kinds of densities.
Because if they didn't have
the right kind of density,
we would have cleaned
it up already.
So that's the ideal.
If you had a copy
of this H somewhere,
then I zoom into
the yellow parts,
zoom into these W's, and I find
lots of copies of H in between
the W's.
So suppose-- let
me write this down.
So suppose the little V's, so
the vertices, lies in the--
so I'm just indexing
where a little v lies.
The little v lies
in big V sub phi
V for some phi which since the
vertices of H2 went through k.
So now we apply counting lemma
to embed induced copies of H
in g where the vertex
V in H is mapped
to a vertex in the
corresponding W.
And we would like to know that
there are lots of such copies.
And the counting Lemma--
or rather, some variant, but I
should read the counting lemma
that we did last time and view
it as a multi-partite version.
Apply this so far part to part.
So we find that the number
of such induced copies
is within a small error.
So that regularity parameter
multiplied by the number
of edges of H, which we
already canceled out,
multiplied by the
product of these Wi's.
So it's within
this error of what
you would suspect if you
naively multiply the edge
densities together along
with the vertex densities.
So these factors are for the
edges that you want to embed,
and then I also need to
multiply the densities
for the long edges.
So 1 minus these edge densities.
So one way you can think
of it is just consider
the complement in g.
So consider the complement of
g to get this version here.
And then finally, the product
of the vertex set sizes.
And the point is that this
is not a small number.
So hence the number of
induced copies of H in g
is at least on the order of--
well, OK?
So it's at least some
number, which is basically
this guy over here.
So epsilon over 4 raised to--
all of these are constants,
so that's the point.
All of these guys are
constants, minus--
so here is the main term,
and then the error term.
And then the product of
these vertex set sizes,
and we saw that each vertex
set is not too small.
So you have lots of
induced copies of H in g.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: How do you
do in the case where
the density between [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so can
you repeat your question?
AUDIENCE: How are you
dealing with the [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: OK.
So question, how do we deal
with the all but epsilon
over two pairs?
So that comes up in
the cleaning step
in what I wrote
in red in dealing
with the number of total edges
that are added or removed.
So think about how many
edges are added or removed.
In these non-exceptional pairs,
the number of edges that are
added or removed--
let's just think
about added edges.
So if the density of V is
controlled by that of W,
then the number of edges added--
or removed, in that case--
from all such pairs along with--
yeah.
So you have epsilon n
squared edges changed.
On the other hand, if this is
not true then you only have
epsilon k squared such pairs ij
for which this cannot be true.
So you also only have at
most epsilon n squared edges
added or removed in such cases.
That answers your question?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Is that number 0?
YUFEI ZHAO: Is which number 0?
AUDIENCE: The number of induced
edges for the [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: The--
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the top board.
YUFEI ZHAO: Top board?
Good.
So asking about this number.
So that should have been 2.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I don't
see k anywhere.
YUFEI ZHAO: OK, so question, you
don't see k appearing anywhere.
So the k in the
corollary, do you mean?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
YUFEI ZHAO: So that
hasn't come up yet.
So it comes up implicitly
because we need to lower bound
the sizes of these W's.
So this is partly why we need
a bound on the number of parts,
but it is true that we do
not need epsilon k to depend
on k in this application yet.
I will mention a different
application in the second
where you do need that k.
OK, so the number of induced H
in g is at least this amount.
And that's a small lie.
You need to maybe consider this
is the number of homomorphic.
Well, actually, no, we're OK.
Never mind.
So you can set delta to
be this quantity here,
and then that
finishes the proof.
So you have lots of
induced copies of H
in your graph which
contradicts the hypothesis.
So that finishes the proof
of the induced removal lemma,
and basically the proof is
the same as the usual graph
removal lemma except
that now we need
some strengthened
regularity lemma which
allows us to get rid
of irregular parts
but in a more
restricted setting.
Because we saw you cannot
completely get rid of irregular
parts.
Any questions?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So I want to
address the question of why
did I state this
corollary in this more
general form of a decreasing
sequence of epsilons?
So first of all, with
strong regularity lemmas,
the strength is sometimes
always nice to--
it's always nice to state
it with this extra strength.
Because it's the
right way to think
about these types of theorems.
That the regularity
on the parts depends--
you can make it depend
on the number of parts
so that you get much stronger
control on the regularity.
But there are also
some applications.
For example, whether
I will state next,
an application where you do
need that kind of strength.
So here's what's known as
the infinite removal lemma.
Here we have not
just a single pattern
or a finite number of patterns
we want to get rid of.
For now we have
infinitely many patterns.
So for every curly H, which
is a possibly infinite set
of graphs.
The graphs themselves
are always finite,
but this may be
an infinite list.
And an epsilon parameter.
There exists an H0 and a
delta positive parameter
such that every n vertex
graph with at most delta--
so less than delta--
V to the H induced
copies of H for every H
in this family with
fewer than H0 vertices.
So every graph
with this property
can be made curly H free.
So it means free of--
induced curly H free by
adding or removing fewer
than epsilon n squared edges.
So now instead of
a single pattern
you have a possibly infinite
set of induced patterns and a
want to make your
graph curly H free--
induced curly H free.
And the theorem is
that if there exists
some finite bound, H0, such
that if you have few copies--
so for all the patterns
up to that point--
then you can do
what you need to do.
So take some time to even
digest this statement,
but it's somehow infinite
versions-- the correct infinite
version of the
removal lemma if you
have infinitely many patterns
that you need to remove.
And I claim that the
proof is actually
more or less the same proof
as the one that we did here,
except now you need
to take your epsilon
case, as in this
corollary, to depend on k.
You need to in some way look
ahead in this infinite pattern.
So here in proof, this epsilon
k from corollary depends on k.
And also it depends on
your family of patterns H.
Finally, I want to
mention a perspective--
a computer science
perspective on these removal
lemmas that we've been
discussing so far.
And that's in the
context of something
called property testing.
And basically, we would
like an efficient--
efficient meaning fast--
randomized algorithm
to distinguish graphs that
are triangle-free from those
that are epsilon far
from triangle-free.
Where being epsilon far
from triangle-free means
that you need to change more
than epsilon n squared edges
here. n is, as usual, the number
of vertices to make the graph
triangle-free.
So the distance, the
[INAUDIBLE] distance
is more than epsilon away
from being triangle-free.
So somebody gives you
a very large graphing.
n is very large.
You cannot search through
every triple vertices.
That's too expensive.
But you want some way to test
if a graph is triangle-free
versus very far away
from being triangle-free.
So there's a very simple
randomized algorithm
to do this, which is
to just try randomly
sample a random
triple of vertices
and check if it's a triangle.
So you do this.
And just to make our
life a bit more secure,
let's try it some
larger number of times.
So some c of epsilon some
constant number of times.
And if you find a triangle--
so if you don't find
a triangle, then we
return that it's triangle-free.
Otherwise we return that it is
epsilon far from triangle-free.
So that's the algorithm.
So it's a very
intuitive algorithm,
but why does it work?
So we want to know that,
indeed, somebody gives you
one of these two possibilities.
You run that algorithm, you can
succeed with high probability.
Question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
YUFEI ZHAO: So let's talk
about why this works.
So theorem, for
every epsilon, there
exists a c such that
algorithm succeeds
with probability bigger than
2/3, and 2/3 can be any number.
So any number that you
like because you can always
repeat it to boost that
constant probability.
So there are two cases.
If g is triangle-free,
then it always succeeds.
You'll never find
this triangle, and it
would return triangle-free.
On the other hand, if g is
epsilon far from triangle-free,
then triangle removal
lemma tells us
that g has lots of triangles.
Delta n cubed triangles.
So if we sample c being, let's
say, 1 over delta times--
delta here is a function of
epsilon from the triangle
removal lemma.
So we find that the probability
that the algorithm fails
is at most--
so you have a lot of triangles.
So very likely you will
hit one of these triangles.
So the probability that the
algorithm fails is at most 1
minus delta n cubed divided
by total number of triples
raised to 1 over delta.
And this is 1 minus at
most 1 minus 6 delta raised
to 1 over delta, and it's
at most e to the minus 6.
So less than 1/3 in particular.
So this algorithm succeeds
with high probability.
Now, how big of a c do you need?
Well, that depends on the
triangle removal lemma.
So it's a constant.
So it's a constant,
does not depend
on the size of the graph.
But it's a large
constant, because we
saw in the proof
of regularity lemma
that it can be very large.
But you know, this
theorem here is basically
the same as a triangle
removal lemma.
So it's highly
non-trivial if it's true.
Even though the algorithm is
extremely naive and simple.
I just want to finish
off with one more thing.
Instead of testing
for triangle-freeness,
you can ask what other
properties can you test?
So which graph
properties are testable
in default in that sense?
So distinguishing
something which
has the property, so P versus
epsilon far from this property
P.
And you have this
tester which is you
sample some number of vertices.
So this is called
the oblivious tester.
So you sample k
vertices, and you try
to see if it has that property.
So there's a class of
properties called hereditary.
So hereditary properties
are properties
that are closed under
vertex deletion.
And these properties are--
lots of properties that you're
seeing are of this form.
So for example, being H3 is this
form being planar so this one
being induced H3, so this
one being three-colorable,
being perfect,
they're all examples
of hereditary properties.
Properties that if your
graph is three-colorable,
you take out some vertices,
it's still three-colorable.
And all the
discussions that we've
done so far, in particular
the infinite removal lemma.
If you phrase it in the form
of property testing given
the above discussion, it implies
that every hereditary property
is testable.
In fact, it's testable
in the above sense
with a one-sided error
using an oblivious tester.
One-sided error means that up
there if it's triangle-free,
then it always succeeds.
So here one of the cases
that always succeeds.
And the reason is that
you can characterize
a hereditary property
by a curly H induced H3
for some curly H. Namely,
you're putting everything
into H that do not
have this property.
This is a possibly
infinite set of graphs,
and that completely
characterizes
this hereditary property.
And if you read out the
infinite removal lemma,
it says precisely, using
above this interpretation,
that you have a property
testing algorithm.